This DNews episode is brought to you by Domain
Dot Com!
Volcanic eruptions may be terrifying, deadly,
and wreak havoc on transatlantic air travel,
but they can also show us how the Earth’s
crust regenerates.
Hey guys, Amy here for DNews.
We might not think about it, but beneath our
feet the Earth is a really active planet.
The crust, the most superficial layer of the
planet, constantly regenerates.
Molten rock in the mantle forms vertical sheet-like
structures called dykes, and as these rise,
they force surface rock apart, typically where
two plates are moving away from one another.
This creates a new portion of crust, but it
usually happens beneath the oceans where we
can’t see it.
But the Bárðarbunga [BARTHAR BOONKA] volcano
in Iceland, which is buried beneath the Vatnajökull
[VATNA yukuk] ice cap, has recently become
active enough to offer scientists a rare chance
to see this resurfacing process in action.
The volcano reawakened in August 2014, and
scientists have been monitoring the magma
flow in the surrounding area using GPS and
satellites.
Specifically, scientists were able to track
the path of the moving magma for some 28 miles
before it reached a point where the volcano
began to erupt.
The slow, long movement of magma comes down
to the way these dykes form and behave.
Dykes form in segments, moving along the path
of least resistance and breaking through cracks
in rocks as the pressure from beneath builds.
This means that the pressure from the mantle
as dykes form can spread out under something
like a volcano and rise to the surface at
points where there are breaks in the crust.
In the case of the volcano in Iceland, scientists
actually measured a dyke change directions
at one point, yielding to the influence of
plate tectonics.
They also uncovered the existence of ice cauldrons,
which are depressions in the glacier ice that
had been melted by magma.
So the active Earth resurfacing itself all
comes down to magma breaking through the pressure
of rock and ice while responding to the pull
of plates moving apart.
And speaking of breaking through things, sort
of, breaking through the internet to get your
story told is easier than ever when you own
your own domain.
Domain Dot Com gives you the power to influence
and control what people find when they search
for you online.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Domain Dot Com is affordable, reliable, and
easy-to-use.
And you can get Get 15% off Domain Dot Com’s
already affordable domain names and web hosting
when you use coupon code DNEWS at checkout.
So what do you guys think about the awesome,
if slow, way our planet resurfaces itself?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.